tengo aquí la gráfica de la función f de
verdad estamos aquí graficando
efe dt y en el eje horizontal digamos lo
tenemos en términos del tiempo que se
mide digamos en segundos y en este tipo
de este tipo de funciones se describen
justamente como ondas cuadradas estas
son ondas cuadradas y en realidad
podemos ver que ésta es una función
periódica verdad y este tiene un periodo
de 2 p
cada dos segundos repetimos un ciclo
entonces vamos a poner justamente esto
el periodo te va a ser 2 pi vamos a
ponerlo así como segundos por ciclo muy
bien vamos a poner esto como segundos
por ciclo y de hecho también podríamos
escribir cual es su frecuencia la
frecuencia de esta función será
justamente el recíproco del periodo es
decir será uno sobre dos y en este caso
serán ciclos por segundo
sobre segundo más bien verdad y lo que
vamos a explorar en este vídeo es si
podemos representar esta función
periódica como una suma infinita de
funciones senos y cosenos que por
supuesto serán de distintos periodos
entonces la idea es escribir nuestra
función
efe dt como una suma de funciones
periódicas verdad entonces vamos a poner
primero digamos una constante a cero
verdad que sea digamos nuestra base y de
hecho ya veremos más adelante que esta
constante tiene que ver con el promedio
de la función verdad y luego vamos a
sumar digamos algunas funciones
trigonométricas que tengan periodo dos
pi y digamos quizás algunas de ellas es
una constante por el coseno de t y otra
quizás podría ser una constante por el
seno de t muy bien en realidad nosotros
empezamos con estas dos funciones porque
sabemos que f dt la función ft tiene un
período de dos segundos por ciclo verdad
así que podemos iniciar con estas dos
en el seno verdad porque éstas también
tienen un periodo de dos y verdad y de
hecho a uno podríamos pensarlo como el
peso que tiene la función coseno de t
para formar a la otra función
efe dt que es ésta amarilla y b1 podría
ser también el peso que tiene la función
seno de t para ser parte de esta función
amarilla entonces por ejemplo si a uno
fueran más grande que b 1 la función
coseno de t tiene un mayor peso o una
mayor importancia para la función
efe dt verdad que que si la comparamos
por ejemplo con la función seno de t
pero esto por sí mismo no describe a la
onda cuadrada en realidad nosotros
tenemos que agregar más términos a estas
una verdad que es que tengan que ver con
senos y cosenos donde vayamos cambiando
la frecuencia verdad entonces por
ejemplo ahora podríamos agregar otra
función
digamos con un peso a dos verdad que sea
coseno
en este caso nuestra función coseno de 2
t tiene un periodo y verdad y la fresco
la frecuencia sería 1 / pi verdad y
también podríamos agregar un 3 por el
coseno de 3 t y así podríamos seguir
agregando más términos pero así como
podemos agregar términos cosenos también
podríamos agregar senos verdad entonces
aquí podríamos agregar b 2 por el seno
de 2 tv3 por el seno por el seno de 3 t
y seguimos agregando otros términos
verdad entonces uno puede puede tratar
de pensar si es posible que esta función
efe dt le escribamos como una suma
infinita de senos y cosenos verdad y en
realidad es un muy buen ejercicio
matemático pero uno podría preguntarse
también bueno porque querríamos para en
principio hacer eso y en realidad toda
esta idea fue explorada verdad fue
explorada por furia idea y toman estas
estas series justamente el nombre
series de furia de verdad furia
justamente estaba interesado en resolver
cierto tipo de ecuaciones diferenciales
verdad son muy interesantes desde el
punto de vista de las ecuaciones
diferenciales porque estas son más
fáciles de resolver por ejemplo cuando
tenemos senos y cosenos involucrados
pero ya no es tan fácil cuando tenemos
digamos una efe efe dt arbitraria verdad
entonces la idea es que si representamos
estas ondas como sumas de senos y
cosenos entonces podemos resolver
ecuaciones diferenciales más generales
otra cosa interesante es que de hecho
son la base del procesamiento de señales
de verdad se usa mucho por ejemplo en
ingeniería eléctrica y la idea es tratar
de interpretar digamos estos pesos que
tienen las funciones seno y coseno
verdad tratar de interpretar esos pesos
como que tanto digamos de cada una de
estas frecuencias que tenemos aquí
contiene la función f entonces por
ejemplo sí
no fuera mucho más grande que la función
que el que el peso a 2 perdón esto nos
dice que tiene más de la frecuencia 1 /
2 pi que de la frecuencia 1 / pi verdad
que son digamos esto lo estamos midiendo
en hertz si quieres verlo así o por
ejemplo si a 3 fuera mucho más grande
que a 2 y que a 1 entonces la frecuencia
de la función coseno de 3 te sería sería
mucho más relevante que la frecuencia de
estas dos funciones verdad y esto nos
ayuda a pensar una función no sólo en
términos del tiempo verdad sino también
en términos de frecuencias y como
veremos más adelante en series de furia
y transformada de fourier esto nos
llevará al dominio de frecuencias verdad
donde podemos empezar a hacer
procesamiento de señales mientras vamos
a explorar esto en los próximos vídeos
para entender cómo hallar los
coeficientes verdad vamos a repasar algo
de identidades trigonométricas en
especial aquellas que se utilizan para
las integrales verdad para resolver
integrales y veremos que también podemos
aproximar esta función